eu acredito que a gente cresce e vai
aprendendo sobre o mundo com algumas
mentiras ao nosso redor
só que de tanto ouvir essas mentiras uma
vez atrás da outra
a gente acaba escolhendo acreditar em
coisas que em fazem sentido
sem perceber que mais tarde elas podem
se tornar os paradigmas que vamos
impedir não só de descobrir mas também
de seguir os nossos sonhos
então pergunto pra vocês
quando foi a última vez em que você
parou para refletir na diferença entre a
maneira como você vê o mundo lá atrás
quando era criança
é a maneira como você vê o mundo hoje já
com as crenças de alguém que talvez teve
que se adaptar ao mundo real
eu percebi uma dessas diferenças em mim
mesmo
já faz alguns anos em um dia muito
normal
eu estava passando por uma praça com meu
irmão ea gente viu no espaço os
menininhos brincando com aquelas
bicicletinhas de criança que parece de
brinquedo sabe
estava tudo normal quando nada passou o
carro de bicicleta do nosso lado super
rápido não dava nem pra entender o que
estava acontecendo e bem na frente das
crianças
ele deu uma freada com o turno com giro
com mortal que sair não sei o que ele
fez
eu tinha visto aquele videogame sabe a
gente para um choque
eu tentei regala olho que não dá muito
certo pra mim e pelo meio das
criancinhas
a gente viu o menininho de uns oito nove
anos
sabe aquele buchinho sim o que não pode
apertar assim tudo vermelho suado
disparado enlouquecido atrás do canadá
bike se pendurou na perna do carro e
começou a pular e gritar que meu deus
que ele tinha que ensina pra ele como
fazer aquilo porque é incrível que ele
também queria fazer igual
e aí eu e meu irmão assistindo aquela
cena
o interessante foi perceber a diferença
da minha reação
porque no começo eu também tinha achado
aquele incrível eu também tinha me
impressionado
naquela época pra ser sincero eu
adoraria saber fazer aquilo tá todas as
meninas da escola vem mas na verdade eu
vi meu irmão fez aquela cara de
adolescente aborrecente sabe isso eu
tenho
a oi eu quero lá se achando
assim que se tinha a ver
hoje acho que eu posso confessar que
aquilo só pode ter sido um recalque né
nada mais e nada menos que inveja por
não saber fazer igual porque de alguma
forma alguma coisa me fazia sentir que
se lá na frente de todo mundo eu também
me deixasse mostrar toda a minha emoção
tudo meu entusiasmo toda a minha
admiração por aquilo que achava incrível
de alguma forma eu ia estar de alguma
forma assumindo uma inferioridade por
não saber aquilo também só que a
diferença porque enquanto isso aquele
macaquinho estava criando a oportunidade
de aprender pensar bem
quando a gente é criança criança a gente
acha tão sensacional as possibilidades
de descobrir mais sobre a vida eo mundo
todo dia mas tão sensacional que cada
nova resposta que a gente consegue
merece toda a nossa atenção e merece
todo o nosso foco todo o nosso
entusiasmo e é disso que a criança cria
aquela coragem aquela coragem de se
aventurar no desconhecido e aprender um
novo uma vez atrás da outra sem parar e
sem parar não né porque a gente começa a
crescer a gente começa a ouvir algumas
coisas que são um pouco diferentes
primeiro se você quiser ser respeitado
você tem que ser o melhor na escola para
tirar as melhores notas
é o melhor salário e liste as melhores
roupas segundo
as pessoas são ruins então a falar com
desconhecidos e não conta da sua ideia e
ninguém se não vou roubar o terceiro
você não precisa de ninguém para ser bem
feliz nem ter sucesso
então lá vai sozinha que você vai ser
mais reconhecida entre outras coisas né
só que nada disso faz sentido porque aí
fica parecendo que a sociedade como um
todo é só individualista e tá tudo
separado nas suas caixinhas
só que se tudo tivesse parado nas suas
caixinhas eu sou eu você é você e aí eu
tenho que me garante enquanto você se
garante ea força do poder que nós juntos
teríamos de construir algo fica deixada
de lado para dar lugar àquele hábito
quais aquele vício que a gente conhece
de ficar o tempo todo se comparando um
ao outro quando a gente vê alguém tendo
sucesso o seu incrível qualquer coisa
seja a inter saúde em ter dinheiro em um
ser feliz ou até em ter aquele corpão
será que a gente pára para se perguntar
refletir no que a pessoa fez para criar
aqui no na vida dela no esforço que ela
colocou no que ela sacrificou o que ela
faz no dia a dia
será ou será que a gente se compara ao
se sentir pior desmerece a pessoa com
alguma justificativa pra gente não sair
por baixo
faz sentido há aquele cara ele é sortudo
o emprego caiu no colo dele aquele outro
ele prefácio ele nasceu pra fazer aquilo
aí mas com a genética dela até eu mais
ou menos assim ea gente sai com nariz
empinado orgulho protegido sem perceber
que naquele momento
a gente pode ter perdido a oportunidade
de aprender a fazer alguma coisa que a
gente também gostaria na nossa vida
no fundo todo esse padrão em todo esse
processo a gente comparar é só resultado
desse paradigma de competição extrema
que a gente está vivendo que têm que
competir com todo mundo o tempo todo
só que será que vale a pena viver essa
ideologia porque se eu começar a focar
nos meus dias a ficar o tempo todo
preocupado em julgar se eu tô acima ou
abaixo de quem está do meu lado
os dias vão se tornar uma guerra de quem
consegue se mostrar mais perfeito do que
o resto não é isso que está acontecendo
nas redes sociais
será que é por isso que as redes sociais
contraditoriamente estão se tornando uma
das principais fontes de pressão da
atualidade
será que não é porque a gente vai lá e
filtra tudo que compartilha pra aparecer
aparentar que a gente tem a vida
perfeita para os nossos amigos sem
perceber que os nossos amigos não
fazendo exatamente a mesma coisa e aí os
nossos relacionamentos as nossas
interações vão gradualmente se tornando
mais competitivas com mais ostentação
que era uma coisa boa em dia mais vazias
na escola o cara tem que estudar para
ser o melhor e passar no vestibular se
não roubar a vaga dele mesmo sem ele
saber se aquilo que ele quer para a vida
no trabalho o empregado tem q performar
e seu melhor da equipe
senão vai ser colega dele a ser
promovido mesmo ele também feliz naquele
trabalho no casamento esposas e maridos
têm que ser perfeitos e conseguir
satisfazer cada necessidade um do outro
senão eles correm o perigo de serem
substituídos formal ou informalmente né
só que no fundo esse ciclo sem fim de
competição não beneficia ninguém
todo mundo sai perdendo porque porque
vamos analisar as duas situações
se eu me senti abaixo de alguém eu vou
acabar criando uma barreira que vai me
separar dessa pessoa por inveja pela
insegurança que eu sinto pronto baixa
autoestima que ela me causa pelo outro
lado
se eu me sentir acima do outro eu também
me diz connectu também cria uma barreira
só que dessa vez de arrogância e cada
vez me fecho mais na minha zona de
conforto e acaba que nenhum dos dois
lados cresce
nenhum dos dois lados aprende encontro
nenhum dos dois lados aproveitar
experiências juntos faz sentido isso sim
só que o maior perigo nesse processo não
é a gente simplesmente se sente isolado
e triste o pior que o outro
estou falando aqui de um assunto mais
sério eu estou falando de um perigo
a gente não consegue entender que a
gente é de um perigo
a gente não consegue entender quem a
gente pode se tornar o porquê da gente
está aqui vou explicar
é mais ou menos assim quanto mais eu
compito tempo todo olhando pra fora para
me comparar com quem está ao meu redor
na tv e na revista
- eu consigo olhar pra dentro e
descobriu que eu realmente quero
quanto menos eu sei o que eu realmente
quero
mas eu vivo e tomo as minhas decisões
segundo as expectativas dos outros
lutando pelas medalhas de sucesso dos
outros mesmo que o sucesso ea felicidade
pra mim tem um significado totalmente
diferente
só que não para por aí
quanto mais a gente vive
seguindo o rumo dos outros mas a gente
se afasta da construção do nosso rumo
autêntico mais difícil fica sentir a
nossa essência mais difícil fica a
entender que a gente é porque a nossa
identidade gradualmente vai se baseando
em conquistas e derrotas de batalhas que
talvez nem fossem pra ser as nossas sem
saber quem você é
fica ainda mais difícil encontrar um
propósito de vida
então nesses momentos eu gosto de
lembrar aquela sabedoria de mãe que
quando eu chegava para ela pedindo pra
fazer alguma coisa porque todo mundo
fazia todo mundo podia ela respondia com
aquele clássico não interessa filho você
não é todo mundo era mais ou menos assim
então qual que é a solução
a gente parar de prestar atenção em todo
mundo e se garantir sozinho não porque
se garantir sozinho é uma das origens de
toda essa bagunça que a gente faz nos
ensinaram que o mundo é escasso
então se eu ganho você tem que perder e
vice versa que pedir ajuda receber ajuda
e demonstrar os meus sentimentos
é sinal de fraqueza que nessa vida não
se pode contar com ninguém então
gostaria de votar essa prova e desafiar
isso com a ajuda de vocês eu peço a cada
um de vocês levantar isso eu fico em pé
eu pedi pra você se concentrar e fechar
os olhos agora leva uma das suas mãos ao
peito e senti o teu coração bater ea
cada batida do coração você vai lembrar
dos momentos mais felizes da sua vida
aqueles grandes momentos
os inesquecíveis os que marcaram a sua
história beleza agora foca em um deles
lembra daquele momento percebe as coisas
que estavam ao seu redor
senti o porquê que você tava sentindo
daquele jeito o que aconteceu naquele
dia só pela rip ou qualquer temperatura
do ar
quem tava com você pode abrir os olhos
a minha pergunta pra você agora é nessa
memória você tava sozinho então pra cada
um aqui que nessa memória tinha alguém
consiga eu peço para você cruzar os
braços com ventava seu lado isso e agora
olhe ao seu redor
olha o seu redor e percebe como a gente
é parecido percebe como que pra gente os
momentos mais relevantes da nossa vida
são praticamente impossíveis de viver
sozinhos
valeu pode sentar então vamos lá eu aqui
agora no palco sozinho um atleta
levantando o troféu no pódio está
sozinho
um cientista depois de décadas de estudo
recebendo o prêmio nobel
essas pessoas estão sozinhas essas
conquistas depender não só delas se a
gente parar pra pensar
ninguém consegue nada sozinho a gente
precisa aprender com os outros se
motivar pelo bem que faz aos outros
a gente recebe o apoio nos momentos mais
importantes dos outros então porquê
porque a gente se deixa convencer de que
sozinhos somos mais fortes que a gente
não precisa de ninguém
é praticamente uma sabotagem voluntária
então por outro lado após falar de como
cooperação em vez de competir cooperar e
cooperação para mim entender que as
pessoas não são ameaças não são
ferramentas não são objetos mas que as
pessoas são as nossas maiores fontes de
aprendizado e as possibilidades mais
incríveis de construir aquilo que antes
sozinho poderia parecer impossível
cooperar entender que quando eu deixo de
ver como concorrentes ao meu lado e eu
vejo potenciais amigos aqueles jogos de
segundas intenções
aquelas estratégias do networking se
transforma em uma rede de aliados
concorrentes se transformam em amigos
aliados prontos pra te ajudar a
construir qualquer sonho que você possa
ter cooperação a entender que são os
relacionamentos que mudou a minha vida
que seus relacionamentos que mudou a sua
que seus relacionamentos que mudam o
mundo cooperação entender que são os
relacionamentos que quebram paradigmas
então o que é melhor competir
o cooper a 12
porque se a gente continuar colocando o
modelo conta outra vai manter o
paradigma de comparar o que é melhor ou
pior
e se a gente pudesse viver um pouco de
equilíbrio dos dois
a gente pudesse juntar a cooperação a
competição a gente pudesse criar um
termo chamado de coopetição prazo legal
né
esse é o desafio que eu trago aqui pra
num pra você e pra todos nós
eu te convidou hoje a cooperar com o
mundo ao seu redor para aprender fazer
acontecer e celebrar com as pessoas que
têm tanto para te ensinar
eu também te convido a competir o tempo
todo sem parar
só que com uma mudança uma mudança de
adversário pedir te pedindo pra competir
com você mesmo
compete com os seus medos compete com a
sua vaidade compete com seus vícios
compete com os limites que você mesmo
decidiu aceitar
talvez assim a gente consiga sentir mais
aqui
eu sei que essa mudança não é nada fácil
eu mesmo tenho sofrido muito com ela mas
cada vez que eu percebo que eu não estou
sozinho nessa jornada
eu tenho coragem pra dar mais um passo
em direção a uma realidade de mais
propósito de mais significado de mais
amor e você por qual realidade você está
pronto para viver